mal gucken mal gucken mal gucken wo mal
gucken wo es hingeht du Dicki machen wir
eure scheiß drauf
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
heidi hat was sagst du bist so hell auf
begeistert oder hält unter begeistert
Freddy wir wünschen dir alles Gute aber
dieses Format funktioniert natürlich
auch
zwei Cocktails die ballern
[Musik]
das das meine ich doch das guck mal wie
der aussehen weil Icon wir wollen etwas
verkaufen kelly hat ihren ersten Song
raus ja
alles Gute super und jetzt machen wir
deswegen Cocktail zu dem Thema denn wie
heißt dein Song stronger than ever die
Promo kommt auch wirklich sehr stark
bald kommt ein neuer Song von mir raus
wow wann kann man sich drauf freuen
Mitte März vielleicht Ende mal März ihr
habt es hier zuerst gehört danke schön
schönen Abend
was heißt denn stronger denn Eva stärker
denn je
und deswegen machen wir heute den
stärksten Cocktail
den wir machen können geil es müssen
mindestens
Alkoholsorten drin sein oh mein Gott und
wir haben nur 30 Minuten Zeit
ich habe mir was neues ausgedacht
ich habe sie schon erzählt ach so ich
habe schon wieder vergessen es gibt
einen neuen challengefaktor
[Applaus]
diese Challenge heißt eingelegt
reingelegt
und was heißt das ich habe hier zwei
Shots gemacht mit eingelegten Säften
dieses Mal eine Mischung aus
champignonsaft Möhren und erbsensaft i
und kichererbsensaft alles zusammen ich
dachte eins das ist alles zusammen aber
wenn man diesen shot trinkt den trinkt
man nämlich freiwillig dann kann man
eine Strafe für den anderen rausziehen
ah das habe ich nicht geschafft das muss
man trinken als short wir waren
einkaufen und werden jetzt unsere
Zutaten vorstellen yes ich habe hier
einmal Champagne weil wir es verdient
haben weil Du es verdient hast
dann habe ich als mein zweiten Alkohol
kommt Kontrolle habe ich gar nicht
gecheckt was das ist wirklich überhaupt
nicht habe ich auch gewundert dass du
den hier in deinem Schrank schon hattest
ja so ein bisschen älter aber da habe
ich erst bei meinem tik tok Cocktails
Video rausgefunden ach was soll's
lecker und dann habe ich hier noch so
ein echter
nordhäuserlikör mit den Fluch ach so und
dann habe ich natürlich noch Minze
gefrorene Himbeeren
das war's nee Capri-Sonne prickelnd okay
fertig du okay also für meine drei
Alkoholsorten denn er muss ja richtig
schön ballern ja dann Cocktail einmal
Lilly das spricht jetzt nicht wirklich
von ballern aber okay
und Wodka Gorbach
und oh
nicht wow ich gehe sogar extra Meile und
auf spontan dann habe ich Swaps
und Selter und Brombeeren eine
Grapefruit in der Heidelberg und ein
Geburtstag
an Zutaten ich habe überlegt
viel Regeländerung
wir haben nur 15 Minuten Zeit geworden
und damit würde ich sagen 8
[Musik]
sechs sechs sieben
sechs sieben
stell den Timer auf 15 Minuten
[Musik]
ich weiß
die Zeit läuft schon du hast schon eine
halbe Minute verschwendet
und bitte Energie
natürlich
schon Kopfschmerzen
[Musik]
activate
du bist auch echt gleich fertig ne
welches Glas nehme ich
cosmopolenten Glas oh wir fühlen beide
glaube ich den gleichen weil
[Musik]
in die Mischung kommt jetzt das ganz
wichtig zwischendrin mal probieren
[Musik]
meine Damen und Herren sehen Sie hier
dieses fantastische Bilder schon an
einem tollen Drink das wird jetzt noch
getoppt nö wird's nicht
so viele Kinder immer bei dir rum ich
glaube die über uns hatten äh ist eine
Tagesmutter
wow nein nein oh mein Gott die Blaubeere
unten im blauen
also ich weiß jetzt nicht was ist mit
meinem Vater
ich muss mal ein bisschen Druck ablassen
[Musik]
mal Essen bestellt und dann kam der so
mit dem Essen ich habe die Tür
aufgemacht habe ich mich gerade voll
erinnert und dann hat er mich so
angeguckt und meinte
du bist die mit der Koffer oder für die
letzten 5 Minuten trinken jetzt noch oh
nein so ich versuche hier im Cocktail
boah das ist richtig scheiße weil da ist
nicht mehr viel Platz oh ist das
schlimmste was ich jemals getrunken habe
ja
jetzt auch noch
das ist zu schlimm eigentlich
[Gelächter]
das nächste Mal ich wollte erst sagen
gar nicht durch meine Nase eingeladen
den Zettel habe ich mir verdient
du musst einen schon vom stärksten
Alkohol trinken du darfst 5 Minuten
vorbei schnell
hallo gib mir doch mal einen Shop Glas
redest du jetzt gar nicht oder was du
sollst du noch einmal reden nicht gar
nicht reden ich echt nein never der
Vodka wie viel ist denn Wodka
37,5 %. scheiße und kostet nicht viele
Cent 40 vielleicht muss ich gleich hier
kotzen oder damit du bescheid weißt
du
was sehr sanft obwohl 40 % sind aber
meine Lippen hey das ist voll schnell
vorbei gegangen auf einmal ich dachte
wir haben voll alle Zeit der Welt du
hast recht du kleiner Specht dicker eine
Minute mach schnell du gute
ach menschenskinder das sieht da einfach
nur kacke aus sieben sechs fünf vier
nein du verarschst mich aus
okay alles klar hier haben wir den
stronger den ever Farbkonzept blau unten
oben pink deswegen haben wir auch
Blaubeeren und Himbeeren und die
Blaubeeren schwimmen aus irgendeinem
Grund im blauen und die Himbeeren oben
das habe ich nicht geplant aber es passt
mir perfekt die Beeren hier oben die
sind so ein bisschen um auch den Rand so
schön säuerlich zu machen die Grapefruit
soll die feminine Energie das Videos und
das Songs wieder spielen kann
da kann man einen bumsen damit er sich
natürlich aktiviert und mit einem Messer
wer kennt also es ist ein bisschen grau
Aussehen kommt ja drauf an wie man
bekommt
okay erinnert ja an einen
mehr ersten whiteberry aber in stark
weil da noch Wodka drin ist und das
war's eigentlich und andere Zutaten okay
hau rein hau rein also meiner ist
einfach strong wegen deiner Aufgabe
Champagne ist und was Champagner in
meinem Musikvideo getrunken wird wenn
ich ja mit meinen Mädels Champagner
dachte ich sowas also für so eine
Situation nachdem du
lässt mich mal ausreden nachdem du
irgendwie mit deinem Ex irgendwie
abgeschossen hast und du denkst scheiß
auf denen das war eher Panne braucht man
ja auch was stärker als Champagne mit
Champion kann man ja anfangen und danach
ich rolle alles in allem ein sehr
feminin ist gedrängt leider nicht
überlegt noch was aus dem Arsch ich
überlege noch das ist die Hinterkappe
das ist die Periode und grün ist
ein bisschen aus wie Sonnenuntergang
[Musik]
hui da kann ich mich ja fast gar nicht
entscheiden was besser ist
findet nämlich meiner schmeckt zu sehr
nach einem ungewollten whiteberry Lily
und deiner schmeckt wie etwas was es
sein sollte
schöner als meiner ja ich will nur die
Himmel hättest du dir sparen können ja
ich habe gewonnen dann nehme ich halt
mit nach Hause oder nicht nur Alkohol
drin ja
hast gut momentan
[Musik]
und er schreibt unbedingt bitte in die
Kommentare was für Straßen es in dem
eingelegt reingelegt geben kann weil ich
habe mir jetzt ein bisschen was
ausgedacht und was machen schwer es ist
mit einem Tag wir sollten auch wenn
diese Dinger zu bringen egal ist
irgendwie
ganz wichtig sorry dass ich dich
unterbreche aber natürlich ist der erste
Link in meiner Beschreibung Link zu
meinem Song schwanger sind über Spotify
auf Apple auf iTunes auf dieser
Aufmaßen everything Apple Amazon music
business Drink Gerichte gegangen und so
classroom
30 machen
bis bald wünscht uns Glück
das schwere Lebenspartner
33-Jährige Arsch dieser Art